welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and this is Rick Blaine the show
where we explain the hidden agenda
behind each episode of Rick and Morty
because if it's one thing we can Morty
fans love it's a new way to explain to
their friends what it's all really about
reminder to subscribe to the Rick's
plain podcast feed wherever you get your
podcast so you will have access to this
new rockstars official Rick and Morty
after-show this will be our Rick and
Morty season for follow-up episode but
as we wait for season four to come out
we are looking at one stand out episode
from each season for season 3 that
episode for me was tales from the
Citadel aka the Rick lantus mix-up aka
the return of evil Morty now I'm gonna
sit down with the co-writer of this
episode Ryan Ridley in just a few
minutes but first let's look at the
tales from the citadel's interweaving
storylines to explore its deeper
metaphor that Rick and Morty as a show
hates politics in the twist ending that
most people remember from this episode
isn't really the ending that matters
this episode departs from our Rick and
Morty as they go to some undersea
adventure to instead follow four
storylines in the newly reconstructed
citadel which Rick had destroyed in the
season premiere first there's a
political campaign story following evil
Morty's rise to the presidency and the
cover-up of the conspiracy it plays out
kind of like a parody of stories like
the candidates with Robert Redford or
The Manchurian Candidate or house of
cards with some nods to the 2016
presidential campaign there's also a
street-level story about a rookie cop
Rick with a jaded veteran cop Morty who
corruptly takes bribes and murders
Morty's it's a similar commentary about
racial justice as the movie training day
and then there's a story line about the
exploited factory worker Rick who
murders his boss and surrenders a
standoff by becoming even more exploited
by the capitalist system that he set out
to overturn similar to Marxist fables
like animal farm or Soylent Green
snowpiercer and Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory which comrades is
appear Mart's and lastly a stand by me
inspired story about four rebellious
student Morty's who end up helping the
man take over someone's farm but you
know we can also read into as a Marxist
statement long story short folks
everything's Marc system look there's a
lot of big ideas going on here and it's
remembered as Rick and Morty's most
political episode with the Citadel as an
obvious metaphor for American politics
this ring especially true considering
the season was written during the 2016
election and like many TV shows released
during 2017 critics kind of looked at
all TV through a very political lens
but here's the thing this episode
actually says a big you to all political
analysis the episode style was not tales
from the Citadel it's the Rick lantus
mix-up the episodes post credit scene is
a true ending because it bookends the
framing scene from the opening we
returned from the Citadel and our Rick
and Morty returned from Atlantis and
Morty asks by the way hey I'm still not
curious about what might have happened
at that crazy sit it out please not at
all Morty that place will never have any
bearing over our lives ever again unlike
that mermaid puss yeah we're gonna do
that every week the final scene reframes
everything as we saw in the Citadel has
just episodes from another series and
the storytelling is so dense for
complete interesting arcs with a
callback to the characters superfans
were most obsessed with and it's as if
the writers cram story ideas for every
political commentary into one episode so
that they would never have to talk about
politics of her again all of season 3
takes place in this a political stance
and the premiere Rick wipes out the
Citadel of Rick's as if he never wants
to be sucked back into the politics and
interdimensional drama ever again and
the finale episode is Rick literally
miss fighting with the Obama like
president over a mere selfie that Morty
wanted this may come as a disappointment
for fans of evil Morty boo I'm sure
would love for him to be more
conspiratorial II involved in a series
end game but even even Morty's final
speech rugs off this responsibility to
be a kind of Emperor Palpatine seems
like a good tune for a drink
cold calculated speech with sinister
overtones speech about politics
but speeches are for campaigning now is
the time for action
even evil morning himself recognizes
that Rick and Morty can be so much more
interesting than political allegory in
any conspiracy twists and mythology
building that the show seems to be doing
like introducing an evil morty in season
one and bringing it back in season three
it's only meant as a vehicle for the
show's true agenda chaos based humor
with reminders that being a genius
doesn't mean you have to be a Rick but
hey that's just my Rick's planation my
full [ __ ] is saying politics don't
matter just a lazy excuse to shield
oneself in a bubble of immaturity route
to political slavery with extra steps
well we've invited the co-writer of this
episode Ryan Ridley on this episode to
explain what it's all really about right
after a quick message from our sponsors
hey guys have you ever been stuck in the
awkward experience of having to buy
cologne for yourself just wandering the
aisles of the Macy's Ursa Force still
wearing that polo your grandma bought
you for Christmas as ago dousing her
nostrils until everything smells like
burning smelling good is important and
that's why I love Hawthorne instead of
smelling a bunch of cents in a store
until they all smell the same Hawthorne
has you take a short quiz about your
lifestyle and preferences and then they
send you two cents one for work and one
for play I love this handy quiz it's got
a scale for Bo that goes from no Bo too
painful Bo hopefully painful strong
enough because well you're lucky
podcasters don't have a spelling future
they also have deodorant shampoo and
body wash the whole process is easy and
convenient best of all it's totally
risk-free with free shipping and free
returns check out Hawthorne and
Hawthorne at dot C oh that's Hawthorne
with an E and use my promo code Ric to
get 10% off your first purchase that's H
aw th oor in e dot co and use my code
Ric to get 10% off your purchase
Hawthorne dot C oh and we're back now
joining this episode of her explained to
help us break down these season 3
episode the Rick Lantis mix-up ok aid
tells from citadel return of evil morty
coming back to the show our friend ryan
ridley thank you for joining us again
thank you again and also join in this
conversation is our our good buddy and
Rick and Morty superfan and
self-described connoisseur of mermaid
sex Sam bachelor howdy
now is that a lighthouse reference or a
reference to this one
now Ryan you co-wrote this episode with
Dan Gutterman and we were discussing
earlier how it seems to be the most
political episode tell us from the
Citadel has like four interweaving
storylines they're all political
allegory in in some kind of sense and it
seems like this is the episode that they
crammed all the political commentary
ideas into because none of the other
episodes of Rick and Morty seem that
political nature they have social
commentary commentary on human nature on
relationships on like mental health but
not so much about like politics and
social structures would you agree that
Rick and Morty is an a political show is
that something that the writers have
talked about yeah I mean it definitely
is although I will remind you that there
is one episode that was a very bald
attempt to be political which is the B
story and I think it was the devil
episode might be wrong but it's one
where Rick and Morty and Jerry go to
Pluto climate change denial the
political status quo that would you deny
it
so and that's not a super great story
and it's not a super memorable story
obviously and the reason is is an answer
to this question is that you know when
you're I think when you're like let's
talk about this but then we'll just
tweak it and make you know half the face
is white or half the fish's black Star
Trek style and it was like that was kind
of very basic metaphors for you know
what they talked about in the sixties
and with Rick and Morty it's like I
think that this episode was born more
out of like the organic political
reality of the universe itself we
weren't going like we're gonna talk
about police brutality or you know every
other whatever the four are there's
three other stories we're talking about
you know the workers rights and all that
kind of stuff there was never really a
we're thinking about that it was just
kind of like what would be the how do
you examine this very complex society
and what's kind of the most interesting
but also funny ways and surprising ways
to see it or not how do you rearrange
Rick's and Morty's and watch them in
different status roles you know the cops
the status is reversed Rick is the low
status character
and and you know so that's and they are
obviously is metaphor the proper term
for that is it's like one of these
things were it's like one ironic started
to become used wrong like am I gonna
come off like an idiot for saying it's a
metaphor I'm technically a writer I
should at least know like writing terms
a lot of sports that ruined ironing for
us yeah and someone else were in
metaphor for us probably yeah so I don't
know analogy whatever the origin of the
episode was Justin was like I want to do
a sit opposite opposite takes place it
all I'm like you know it was always good
to be sort of a little more driven by
the fun of that and less about you know
more the energy of the first episode
which was you know it's fun to see brick
selling little dolls of Morty and all
that kind of stuff there was gonna be a
storyline in fact this is the one thing
I'm were Justin kept whining was that
that it was there was a Rick's store on
the Citadel that Jerry was working at ok
and I'm worried was his boss and it was
like so it was sort of gonna be dealing
with that power dynamic but that that
went away and I remember for me you know
I was like I want that episode and
you're a goober and I were like we want
that episode together because we had the
setup of the season 1 premiere of The
Citadel getting you know attacked I was
like well this is obviously like what
happens when a society gets attacked or
getting devastated in some way and you
know I thought about Iraq a lot after
the war and I was like you know all
these powers-that-be come in and
factions start start you know like you
know springing up and and it's the the
power dynamic the status quo is totally
thrown for a loop and I was like that's
so rich like we can just explore what
that's gonna look like you know so it's
yes of course it's a political episode
but it's not like we're gonna talk about
Iraq I was just kinda like that's what
would happen to this citadel like given
the the premiere episode of season 3
it's interesting yeah it seems like
season 3 was the year when like at least
the reaction to the show people start to
view it through a more like political
lens a more socially woke lens like
people started to do more Theory essays
I'm like is Rick a good person should he
be a role model like more conversations
is about
Rick and Morty fanbase and it might have
just been this is the first season to
come out after the 2016 election and I
feel like all the television started to
be like looked at through that lens
whether or not the writers intended it
to be that did you guys feel like a
greater pressure like to dig into more
of those themes like how did you guys
react to that reaction I mean I see so
we would have been writing the season
because I remember ending the season or
me finishing my role like just before
the election I remember walking I
remember like I hadn't seen Dan in like
a week and he used to live in my
neighborhood so I like walked at home
like the day of the election or day
after the election I like and of course
that's that was the first moment I was
like this is actually real for months
before that people were like I don't
know this could this could be one big
joke this you know who knows so when
we're probably writing this episode I
don't remember where we would have been
like the summer of 2016 or something
like that and it other than the obvious
parallel between the political you know
it's a it's a campaign happen you know
and you could obviously although the the
truth is the more evil Morty who ends up
being evil Morty it's almost the
opposite of Trump he's someone
pretending to be virtuous and Breezies
you know he's manipulating and he's
hiding his Cydia sness he never speaks
his mind he's always got like a truth
where it's you know Trump speaks yeah
yeah and so I you know that I you know
obviously there's a connection but I
think we would have probably done that
anyway I think it was more influenced by
you know just if Trump wasn't winning if
there wasn't even an election happening
that year we would have probably had
that because it just makes sense to sort
of like I said it it it's you know there
would be a new political reality given
everything that happened to the Citadel
and and there's demographic shifts and
there's there's there's civil rights
movements and stuff like that and so I
think it was we it obviously wanted to
bring evil Marty back but you don't just
want to force him back you don't want to
force anything
obviously like if it's really you're
staying true to what the you kind of let
the story tell itself and all of a
sudden I think it was Danny said like oh
that more you should be evil Marty and
this isn't the perfect way to finally
bring him back and also it's it's
it shows that he's even more diabolical
than you would assume based on the close
Rick counters episode from season 1
which was just sort of more like a I
don't know what he is planned well
second I was kind of more hasty and it's
kind of structure this was like next
level this is like he's possibly taking
over the galaxy universe multiverse yeah
that one the first appearance felt like
a teaser or stinger and like a
post-credits scene
whereas this felt like oh no this was a
master plot like a Palpatine level type
thing and in this episode of your evil
Morty storyline but you cannot dive into
what it took to like manage all of these
storylines and you mentioned one that
was on the cutting room floor and you
had to drop it but were there any other
ones that kind of come to mind that were
on the cutting room floor I mean once
again I think I said in previous episode
you know there it was one of those
things where it's like just the very
beginning it's like well what should the
stories be and so people were pitching a
lot of different things and I don't
remember what you know obviously we
decided in those four that felt like a
good cross-section like you know but I
do remember that there was a there's a
time when once the scripts start getting
longer and longer and that means that
the it just that's effects production
somebody said well why don't we cut the
stand by me one with the four Morty's
and I don't know if we're just because I
was like particularly I know I just felt
like I'm like no it's for feels like the
right number the ring balance and also
that they all tell us there's no overlap
they all really tell four unique stories
like well what would it be was just all
this what would it be in all the Morty's
what would it be it was just you know
the Rick and Morty party and make flip
what would it be and I was like fighting
to make sure we didn't cut that I don't
remember what I did maybe I just started
trimming things out a little bit but I
mean there's definitely I'm trying to
think of what things we cut that were in
that there's probably a lot of stuff
that was cut if nothing else like little
details like more you see more on TV
right like I remember we wanted to kind
of show like commercials for TV shows
you know what would what would Rick and
Morty you know what would be Rick and
Morty the citadel's Breaking Bad be you
know I mean like some show where Rick's
always made to look awesome because it's
basically Rick propaganda you know that
probably stuff like that
but with like Rick and Morty features
even more turkey coming back in this
episode
it has like interesting way that the
episode ends in the post-credits scene
where like you know they come back from
Atlantis and then Rick has this line
like this we'll never have any bearing
on our lives again so we're like are we
done with evil Morty does that what that
means like this you saw his rise and we
will never have a look about him again
no I think that that's that was meant to
be ironic and I think that is the proper
use of my my girlfriend loves this
expression dramatic irony which is you
know and she talks about how when she
was younger he would get stressed out in
a movie watching a character who is
behaving in a way you know it's like a
classic horror movie said I'm you know
that you know the audience knows
everybody in the movie is gonna be
threatened by some horrible force before
the characters do so there's that
dramatic irony of like ah they don't
know there's a they just open the closet
they're looking the other way and
there's a killer with a machete in there
you know that's what it is Rick is rick
is an idiot his his own his own contempt
for the Citadel and what it represents
and kind of everything outside of his
own what he wants to do is on a
selfishness is he's oblivious to how
much of a threat and how much there is
out there waiting for him and how
there's a foe who has been I mean that's
probably where parallels the the
election of 2016 frankly is that you
know there is a certain complacency on
behalf of I guess the left liberals that
like well this guy is an idiot he's
depth worried we were the smart ones you
know and and that's probably what's
going on in that moment Rick is like I
don't to worry about those idiots
it's you know and and I'd certainly
don't have to worry about a morty and
it's it's so all it's just like it's
this threat that he's just he's just his
his narcissism is just making him blind
- yeah so no it's definitely not meant
to be interpreted by the text I think
it's more about its subtext right and so
I think you know in the mermaid push the
Atlantis episode which I can give you a
little trivia bit about is like what
could be the dumbest most opposite at
Rick and Morty episode like
inconsequential you know story was the
was the mermaid thing so that was the
fun of gonna book ending it like we're
gonna follow that
no we're not we're actually gonna follow
something like this so so when that
episode I remember we wanted to fool the
public with that reveal and so the
episode is starting to go out and
meaning it was I don't know on Wikipedia
or on IMDB is like tales from the
Citadel coming out whenever that was
October of 2017 or something and all of
a sudden I remember ena in custom a dude
you've got to cheat like people are
gonna know if you want to mislead people
no the episode title there's no mislead
so then all of a sudden it became the
Rick Landis mixed up as the official
title which is funny it's like that is
the official title now but it's really
tails no Citadel I mean I have like a
shirt at home that my friend got me
that's tail that's that graphic font
just that title I was like this is
awesome well thank you so much for
joining us in helping us break down the
Rick lantus mix-up aka tales Macedo Ryan
it's been great to have you to chat
about this again and thanks of course to
Sam basher for joining us you can follow
him on Twitter and Instagram at Sam
batcher and we will be back next time
you see us we will be looking at the
season four premiere episode and we're
also going to do a breakdown of all the
animation details and Easter eggs that
you missed from the episode as we always
do and as a reminder subscribe to Rick's
plain podcast feed wherever you get your
podcasts and right after the season 4
premieres Rick's plane will become the
official Rick and Morty after show of
new rock stars and we're gonna have some
great guests we're going to go inside
the episode to look at some things they
might not have known otherwise and
subscribe to know rock stars on YouTube
as well and you can find all of our Rick
and Morty content both on YouTube and on
our podcast feed thank you for joining
us and see you next time bye bye